the English actress Anna Neagle once
said solitude is pleasant loneliness is
not well solitude is just part of the
job for Michael dawn today is his first
day as the official hermit in the Swiss
city of solo Turin the job dates back to
the Year 1440 to for nearly 600 years
the hermit has been in charge of
maintaining to ancient chapels and a
residence situated in an alpine gorge
but it's not all quiet prayer in
reflection in fact the Hermit needs to
be a bit of a social butterfly a key
part of the job description is to
interact with the streams of tourists
who flocked to the picturesque setting
it was that lack of seclusion that has
forced the last two Hermits to quit you
know 22 other people actually tried for
the job what you get paid $24,000 a year
unless you get room and board how do I
know you know sneak somebody in to live
with you well they do have to talk to
people so it's not I mean you're sort of
a hermit but not really you get a sort
of an acting not a bad job